los 14 expertos de la organización
mundial de la salud visitan hoy dos
centros de control y prevención de
enfermedades en luján para averiguar
cómo se reaccionó en las primeras etapas
es el cuarto día de la misión que
investiga sobre el terreno los orígenes
de una pandemia que ha dejado más de 2
millones de muertos en todo el mundo en
jornadas anteriores pudieron visitar
hospitales y mercados ayer le tocó al
célebre mercado de juanan del que aún se
desconoce hoy si fue el origen o el
catalizador de la pandemia estudios
científicos han revelado que dos
terceras partes de los primeros 42 casos
no tenían vínculos directos con el
mercado y los análisis realizados sobre
sus cañerías y suelos han revelado a su
vez que los vídeos encontrados allí no
pertenecían a animales sino a personas
infectadas lo que sugiere que el primer
salto de animal a personas se habría
producido antes en otro lugar el mercado
fue desinfectado y cerrado tras los
primeros casos por lo que parecía
altamente improbable que los expertos
pudieran encontrar nuevas evidencias
pero ayer twittearon después de la
visita que ésta había sido muy
importante
para entender los orígenes de la
pandemia está previsto que la misión se
alargue durante dos semanas y termine
con el año nuevo chino que es cuando el
país se paraliza y la población celebra
en familia las vacaciones más relevantes
de su calendario